okay let's go next to our caller from
the 941 area code who's calling today
from 941.
hi david this is william i'm from
florida william from florida what's
going on
hi david i really like your show i just
want to put that out there for right now
thank you um so my question's a little
broader
in spectrum um i uh
i've recently gotten into small
government politics just because
i work in substance abuse field and we
get a lot of governmental funding and
stuff like that
um now william just i'm sorry to
interrupt you but
do you mean do you mean small government
as in small government concern
conservatism or just local politics do
you mean
just look local county politics oh got
it okay okay good good
good just mostly kind of i've kind of
had to just to learn where the money's
coming from where it's flowing from
stuff like that to help clients get
resources and things like that
yep um but one thing that i've noticed
since the outbreak
is a lot of that funding has kind of
disappeared
and a lot of the resources it seems like
people don't know where their phones are
and uh and i was wondering do you think
this is a direct correlation
between what's going on in the
larger terms politically with trump and
all those things
um do you think that these things can be
related i know that that's a very
specific question
um we'll listen and uh and for the most
part i realize i live in a red state
the answer is probably different in
every instance so
there's no question if your question is
is
funding to specific programs you're
interested in being cut
because of trump the answer would
probably be
i have no idea unless we look into it
specifically and
probably not but where i think the more
direct connection is that is not getting
a lot of attention you know there's a
lot of
talk about if there's not if people are
unemployed
where do they get money to spend stuff
in the economy small businesses need
people coming in with money to spend so
we've got to get money to people either
through unemployment or through stimulus
the part that's being ignored is
directly related to what you're bringing
up which is
if the government is collecting
less revenue from payroll taxes in
states that have payroll taxes
and if there are moratoriums on this or
that or whatever
states have less money to then
redistribute back out to all sorts of
different programs now you'd have to
look at it at the state by state and
program by program level like in other
words
is there is is there a specific answer
in florida
i i just don't know you'd have to look
that up but certainly what people have
to understand is the state government
can only
take in reduced revenue for so long
before they are going to start saying we
can't afford to fund this program and
that program and that is certainly going
on
right okay well that makes a lot of
sense um
i just like i said i've just seen over
time
um like i said i work directly with
clients i actually work in
a county jail and i work with inmates
rehabilitating them who have dealt with
substance abuse
i've dealt with substance abuse um so we
we have a correlation there like we can
relate on those levels and so i get
um emotionally attached to these people
a little bit yeah
and uh which is part of my job um
and then uh and then i try to i try to
connect them to as many resources as
they can to be successful
upon exiting the gl system or the prison
system
and so uh it's just been kind of
heartbreaking to see like
and i understand i get it when you put
it in terms like that
as in the government can't give us money
if they're not making any
you know um and so uh but that's
i i i thank you for simplifying it to me
because like i said i'm new to these
things
i never before trump got elected i never
thought once
about politics i didn't mean to you know
what i mean
do you um do you mind what what
substance specifically would were you
struggling with
and i'm curious how did it start with a
prescription from a doctor or how did it
start
yeah i actually had a i had a sports
injury in high school
and um i was first prescribed percocet
and um and i was
i was a nerd in high school so i i
thought i would freak out
if i smoked it um but opiates were the
first thing that i took
that gave me that feeling of
i don't have to think about my problems
it was the absence of pain
so um so that's that's where all that
came from
and it was right at the beginning i'm 27
now yeah it was right at the beginning
of the opiate crisis
um and so with the legal prescription
you got hooked and then it continued
after you no longer needed them
for the injury oh yeah the obsession had
begun
that whole wheel started turning of
well if this worked this way if one is
good two was better
yeah right um right and uh and if i
if that helped with that pain then maybe
from trauma and things like that that i
experienced in my life that i had never
identified before
um maybe these other things will work
and for people who hear this and say
well
why couldn't you just start weaning
yourself off
slowly like it just doesn't work that
way does it
no no well because you're no it's you're
not dealing with the drugs it doesn't
have anything to do with the drugs
the drugs are just the most highlighted
part
of the problem right right like like
because we all experience vices in our
life whether it's with money or sex or
power
you know what i mean um but uh but that
that is the easiest way for someone with
an addictive personality
um because it's insta it's instantly
gratifying
right um just like spending spending
money on a pair of shoes that you didn't
really want to begin with right you just
want to hear that kaching sound
yep um and so uh so yeah that's kind of
it's it's not as simple as just quit but
i understand why people say that because
explaining to addiction to a quote
unquote like to a person who's never
dealt with it is almost like explaining
yellow to a blind person like it's
really difficult even if they really
want to understand even if they love you
or respect you um so that and that's
partially been my job as well is to
is to talk to these representatives and
things like that about that
and get them to understand um
you know why it is that people do need
help why they need those resources
and they need um some attention you know
what i mean
absolutely william well said um no thank
you
thank you for calling in i appreciate it
thank you so much sir all right take
care we're gonna go to a quick break if
you are holding don't hang up because
we'll go right back to the phones after
this short break